[Music]
in insta surgeon news submitted by Sauer
onion what's that yeah stomachache
waiting to happen
women are turning to Instagram to find
plastic surgeons and is getting done
Gerasa Instagram yeah cuz you can see
pictures of their former clients so you
could be like oh I want to look like her
oh that guy did a good job on that girl
yeah are these Instagram doctors like
their office in their garage so there
was this paper published in aesthetic
surgery Journal that looked at Instagram
results for 21 surgery related hashtags
like boob job facelift liposuction and
Brazilian Butt Lift like all those
hashtags and they found that 1.8 million
tagged post and then so they found that
there were 1.8 million tagged post right
so they looked at the top nine of both
posts in each hashtag and the majority
of those posts we were shared by people
that like for insurgents or people are
not even qualified to do these
procedures there's a doctor Nick's next
oh yeah Simpsons yeah absolutely
hi everybody hey doctor Nick yep he's a
veterinarian that does I like you yeah
human stuff so then they found that 26%
were shared by doctors like OBGYNs or
dermatologists that they're not even
certified to do a lot of these
procedures there were even there was
even this one hair salon dentists spas
so it's like the only have an actual
plastic surgeon but they're cheap are
they selling the procedure yeah he's
doing a service or they're just sharing
like oh we like this nose job uh well
then I really go into details like that
but I'm assuming that they are sharing
procedures that there's they supposedly
did themselves what kind of deals we're
talking
like oh how much how much are we talking
about he's drawing my first and [ __ ]
like two-for-one nose job bring a friend
and buy it yeah right
you should never it's like getting like
discount LASIK man like you don't get
buy one I get the other three that's
good idea now you know I mean like come
on now or it's like you don't want to
Labor Day Sale for that yeah that feels
bad you need discount medical procedure
yeah I don't know like it's a lot I've
met girls that like are obsessed with
plastic surgery like they really want to
get all these procedures done it always
felt ugly or whatever and to them it's
like a life it would be a life changer
for them and I know like one girl
personally that like she started to go
fund me to try to get a nose job instead
and so if you told her hey this is half
the price of all the nose tells you been
looking at and look how good it is like
I know for a fact she would sign up for
that yeah like like it's a dream come
true
like she's been putting out into the
universe and now like here's the answer
she's been blessed with this opportunity
so like I think you could play on a lot
of people's emotions that way because
there's a lot of girls that are like
obsessed with changing one part of them
and if they had the money they would if
you had one thing that you could change
about yourself physically what would it
be my stomach okay that was fast yeah
that's the first time I actually heard
non-face or big body part yeah I'm fine
with that first time I heard from
someone like like from a girl that it's
nothing here and nothing here it's it's
it's here what don't you like about your
stuff but it's a lot that's where all my
fat goes and like no matter how hard I
work out or diet or anything no matter
what the balance of protein fat and
carbs are no matter what I always have
like a layer of fat that won't go away
it just does not think you know what you
should do though this is what I do I
call it comparative happiness yeah you
look at somebody who's way fatter than
you and you go Louis I'm not that
what's also I don't even notice you have
belly fat because I never wear like a
bikini or whatever but it's really not
also just the way like my torso is
really short and so I feel like my belly
button looks like horizontal you know
like a flat belly button something doing
this and like it just
I feel like it looks fatter than it
actually is in pictures and in like in
life like I just feel like it looks more
fat I really focus banging it's [ __ ]
looking negative scream like I've always
like thought about that like would I get
lipo I'm too scared of surgery so I
would two kinds of belly fat and one I'm
trying to get rid of is the visceral
yeah and then subcutaneous is the inner
one so if you touch your belly and if
it's really like harder but it's it's
kind of like you're bloated that's the
internal fat and then that's what okay
the subcutaneous is kind of like the
love handles so you can kind of go like
this and you pinch that yeah one is fat
around your organs yeah that's a
dangerous that's what that's from high
consumption of sugar
yeah and that's where the beer belly
comes from I don't drink sodas like I
eat mostly plant-based do you know like
sometimes eight fish I mean there's a
way for you to figure it out you just
need to have somebody watch your diet
and they stick with you see what works
and what does it just takes time yeah
yeah like for Bart - Bart found out that
originally he was eating more higher
protein less carbs yeah and he was
gaining weight so he actually bumped up
his carbs and kept his present on the
same amount and he started losing weight
yeah so everybody's a little bit yeah
and this is coming for the factory guys
guys you know can you physically train
me my physical trainer I'm basically a
gym trainer at 24 this through my like
you go up through the most ripped guy in
the world like using your forms of
reforms
hey bro check the form she's gonna walk
off real quick right like you know you
could do a little bit's like that's
wearing an upper resume
dude there's so many Internet
entrepreneurs that come on the comments
and talk about [ __ ] you should be
doing your business this way and that
way and I'm all like shut the [ __ ] up
dude yeah what have you done yeah well
that's the only thing about about like
not losing a certain part like everyone
has they're like all right that holds
their fat and and like everyone if you
if you complain about it do you have a
million opinions of like oh you should
be doing this well you should actually
be doing it [ __ ] you don't know what I
do on a daily basis like I swear to god
this [ __ ] does not go away but it isn't
matter like I'm fine with myself I'm
like totally sad about it but I if I had
to pick one thing it would be that was
it years no cuz we knew that that was
her insecurity
dude like showing my ears maybe like
five years ago like me so I got rather
show you my tits in my ears before
secure it was about me it's always
you're in your own mind yeah I'm sorry
for [ __ ] is a total bit and I didn't
know that
no I it doesn't bother me anymore cuz
now I am like whatever it doesn't who
cloud you on your ears real hard oh it
was actually this guy named Travis or
Dalton I don't know he's like was oh
they were twins and it was a
seventh-grade after school I had my hair
done like a really low ponytail so my
ears look really big cuz it was like
really those and this guy you ran past
me he goes haha you have big ears and
that [ __ ] shattered
I'm gonna call you Dumbo can we call
them satellite ears
it went you can see it some wind
resistance up there any no and then from
there seems like seventh grade up until
maybe like two years ago I think I
forever had my ears nose oh my god so I
would like pray and like I wish that I
would get like surgery or I would see
that sort of saying you must have been
devastated when Obama won because you're
like great now everyone's gonna make
your jokes like your jokes are gonna be
like really common because you got some
bill finally eventually you realize how
beautiful about you what's your thing
I've always wanted to get my teeth fixed
but that's not really cosmetic surgery
but the second thing would be my nose so
your nose yeah I don't see what's really
nice see that's the thing everyone has
its when I smile like it starts to go
down more and then it looks crazy and
then when I wear glasses it's too thin
we see perfection that's our problem
[ __ ] hang she has to remind me to
keep losing weight
I'll get my dick reduced yeah I have she
has to keep reminding me how hard I got
a workout cuz every day I look at the
mirror and she sees me flexing like a
[ __ ] I'm like down and she goes
you need bigger chest oh man why does it
gotta be you like that's what we get
every day we get like just people
telling us you gotta work on all the
[ __ ] people tell you that you like girls
in general like all the media is like
you gotta look like this and then people
on life they nitpick on the DOMA thing
like people have made comments on my
hairline am i no really yeah comments on
my nose like dude you need like really
like aggressive like you need a nose job
comments and like I have a half Filipino
nose like my dad's nose is like really
flat and my mom's nose was like really
long I have a combination of their doses
and I'm
I'm fine with it I don't give a damn how
pretty my friends are we're like I just
like we just want to drink beer and
watch you have seen eyes like oh you
like you like the same [ __ ] I like
counterintuitive like when a girl dies
leaving these comments you know it is
it's the guys who think that bringing a
girl down a peg will make them more
available to you yeah it's true cuz I
know for sure so it's the bottom feeder
guys yes what I've seen for me it's a
lot of like 12 13 year old guys - yeah
little boys little boys are the pickup
or some foreigner guys like there's a
lot of foreigner guys say stuff I'm like
okay my nose doesn't look like the girls
in your country I get it okay yeah I had
no idea that my lips were small until I
started getting on camera people like
where's your upper lip my way all the
time the fatter I got the less clothes I
wore
well you're yeah I mean if people made
one of my ears now like I'm comfortable
with them now they bother me because he
kept making fun of them not like oh yeah
actually this is kind of dumb for me to
be all self-conscious of it
see that's what got you over it Bart
made honey I have a little pregnancy
pouch like at least every video oh my
god yeah oh let's all make fun of her
about it and we'll be there now - really
yeah yeah well now I am kind of
accepting it more like good I want to be
pregnant it's good I got married I'm
fine if I was pretty good right
then at least I'd have an excuse for
this day maybe I'm just stupid because
what would you get surgery on no I'm not
self-conscious or anything I just laugh
because I can see it when other people
pointed out like you know how like I
opened up my eyes and they get smaller
[Laughter]
haunts my dreams like I feel like I'm
gonna wake up one day and he's gonna be
doing that and then I'm gonna have a
heart attack yes I'm gonna die oh [ __ ]
Neil Neil Tyson would be like what the
[ __ ] is that
or like when I gained weight I thought
who was the funniest thing because I've
been so skinny all my life so I never
really saw it as like people call him a
chipmunk yeah I got these fat cheeks I
don't know it was fun uh it's just
difficult maybe because I'm not I was
never a sex symbol so it's like hmm
that's my thing I was never Tiger Beat
so my tiger maybe if I was like people
kept calling me like oh you so sexy and
then like that was my identity and it's
just crushed yeah there's a lot of men
that have low self-esteem yeah they get
a lot of surgeries
dude it's a good Sharon Stone [ __ ] dude
I'm like every movie I'm like she's
trying to like take off her clothes and
we're like you do please don't like
they're like Madonna yeah please it's
chill it's chill man just relax my ex
was really body conscious though like we
weren't even allowed to go to the beach
because he didn't want to get a shirt
off at the beach I can't wait to take my
shirt off at the beach man it's hot
there I get yeah I feel uncomfortable
when my friend doesn't want to take I
understand like what guys don't what you
know bigger guys don't want to take we
know you're fat under that shirt he's
like insecure it's so weird to be my
guys like now I'm gonna take listen
you're fat with or without the shirt
yeah it's just one you're sweating and
the other one you're not so maybe it's
more than that and also that shirt looks
like it's having a bad time yeah
these Astra feel bad for the strip come
on bro just take it off man I hope you
guys enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]